Đó, vài trước ngán trên khai tý điểm vùng phát thay thấp,
huy ban trân thình phố Hanoi và Giá Pá Giá Đó,
giá đoạn một tự kê bùng vô tháng bày đến ngày bà biếm móc
tháng 12 năm ngày gì được trọng 2 bây giờ,
thì điểm tại khu vực vực vô bà hai thuộc phần hoàn kiếm,
trong thời gian này, thích vô hạn chế tất cả phức tiền lưu thông,
từ mấy chiến giờ đến 2 bây giờ, các ngày tý sau thú bài và chủ nhật,
tại khu vực đi bộ quanh vô hoàn kiếm và trở đêm.
Các vấn tịt yêu tiền vẫn được phạt đầu tiền thường,
lối với xa ông công nghệ xíp ở công nghệ và xe máy cán dân,
thành phố quyến khích hạn chế lưu thông, lối với các vấn tịnh bố không cấm hoàn toàn.
Đây đoạn 2 từ ngày 1, 1 tấm 1 đến ngày bà biếm 1 tháng 12,
nằm gìm cụ trọng trọng bị bài, vàng vi tý điểm, lượng bà dòng xang hú vực cửa năm.
Thánh phố dự kiến cấm xe vô tô sẽ gần máy kinh dân bàn tài,
sự dụng giết liệu hóa thèc lưu thông trong vùng phát thè thấp.
Đồng thời tiếp tục quyến khích người dân hạn chế sự dùng xa máy cố,
và tăng cường sự dùng phương tiền công cậm phương tiền vi cơ giới.
Các sẽ tài của khối đường toàn 1,5 tấm cũng xa bị cấm lưu thông, cho khu vực này.
Đây đoạn 3 thực hiện trên toàn 1,5 tấm ra, từ ngày 1,5 tấm 1,5 tấm đứa,
đến ngày bà biếm 1 tháng 12, nằm hai gìm trọng hai bì chiến.
Tức kếp 1 tấm 1,5 tấm 1,5 tấm vâng nguyai, hạn nội dụng kiến cấm xa vô tô,
sẽ gần máy kinh dòi bàn tài, sự dụng xanh lưu thông trong vùng phát thè thấp.
Đồng thời cấm xa máy cán dân, trải xanh khốc đặt quy trần kỹ thải mới bà trở lên.
Như vậy sau với các sự thảo trước đây, thấy điểm áp dụng quy định lối với xa máy xanh khốc đặt trần,
tại khu vực bài đai bột. Đức lối từ ngày 1 tháng 12, nằm hai gìm cậu chào hai bì tấm.